les animaux d'élevages ne sont pas assez
protégés au Québec c'est ce que soutient
la SPCA de Montréal qui veut faire
changer les choses on a vraiment un
système à deux vitesses on a d'un côté
nos animaux de compagnie qui se font
l'objet de réglementation etc et on a de
l'autre côté tous les animaux les
millions d'animaux élevés pour la
consommation dans la province qui eux
sont complètement laissés pour compte
dans nos lois considérant que l'animal
est un être doué de sensibilité dans une
campagne intitulée ce n'est pas parce
qu'ils vont mourir qu'ils ne mérite pas
d'être protégé l'organisme évite la
population à se joindre à ses rangs tout
comme une trentaine de personnalités qui
ont imposé leur voix telles que le
réalisateur Xavier Dolan le chanteur
Paul Piché ou encore l'humoriste
Jean-François Mercier on est dû pour un
changement d'approche complètement sur
le plan des normes applicables en
matière de protection pour les animaux
la loi sur le bien-être et la sécurité
de l'animal a été adopté au Québec en
2015 elle interdit à quiconque de
compromettre le bien-être d'un animal ou
de lui infliger de la détresse une loi
qui selon le gouvernement protège tous
les animaux honnêtement
la portée de la loi j'y retrouve tous
les animaux de domestiques au sens où
les animaux de ferme c'est des animaux
qui sont domestiqués ce qui touche les
grandes filières il y a vraiment un code
de code de conduite si on veut ou un
code de bonne pratique qui sont
développées qui sont mises à jour c'est
tiennent aussi les principaux concernés
ces producteurs-là doivent renouveler
leur certificat pour être sûr qu'ils
puissent vendre leurs animaux un
producteur qui ne respecterait pas ça
free faillite aussi simple que ça parce
qu'il y a plus personne qui serait
autorisé à battre ses animaux
rien dans la loi actuelle ne force les
producteurs à adhérer au code de
pratique qui régissent les lesages des
animaux ici Daniel Piaggio Radio-Canada
Montréal